[تصفيق]
محمد حسني مبارك رمز
للاستقرار والاعتدال لمحبيه
رمزا للديكتاتورية بالنسبة لمنتقديه الذين
تدربوا كطيار مقاتل في الاتحاد السوفيتي ،
صعد مبارك تدريجيا في
الرتب التي تولى قيادة القوات الجوية المصرية
قبل وقت قصير من حرب يوم الغفران عام
1973  عندما شنت مصر وسوريا
هجومًا مفاجئًا على إسرائيل بعد
ذلك بعامين ، عين الرئيس أنور السادات
مبارك نائباً للرئيس بعد ست سنوات من
ذلك في عام 1981 أصبح رئيساً
بعد اغتيال السادات
على يد مقاتلين إسلاميين ،
كان مبارك مع السادات في ذلك اليوم الدراماتيكي
وفقط.  نجا بصعوبة من
رصاصات القاتل نفسه حيث خاض الرئيس مبارك
حربا طويلة ودموية ضد
المسلحين الإسلاميين المصممين على الإطاحة
بنظامه ، وبلغ الكفاح ذروته في عام 1997
عندما قتل المسلحون أكثر من 60
شخصا معظمهم من السياح الأوروبيين واليابانيين
في أعقاب الهجوم
الذي سحقته قوات الأمن المصرية.
المسلحين بينما اتهمت جماعات حقوق الإنسان
المب  نظام أراك
للتعذيب والانتهاكات على نطاق واسع كان الرئيس مبارك
ضيفًا منتظمًا في البيت الأبيض
وشكلت القوات المصرية أكبر
فرقة عربية في القوة متعددة الجنسيات بقيادة الولايات المتحدة
والتي أخرجت الجيش العراقي من
الكويت في عام 1991 ولكن الصداقة كانت لها
حدود 12 عامًا  في وقت لاحق ، رفض مبارك
الانضمام إلى تحالف الرئيس جورج دبليو بوش الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحدة ضد صدام حسين ، وكان
رد فعله فاترًا لإغراء دعواته
للإصلاح الديمقراطي في العالم العربي ، ولكن
تحت ضغط شديد من واشنطن ،
بدأ مبارك في تخفيف قبضته على السلطة
في سبتمبر 2005
أول انتخابات رئاسية على الإطلاق يشارك فيها العديد من المرشحين
بينما حقق خصومه
الإخوان المسلمون بعض المكاسب ،
لا يزال مبارك متمسكًا بقوة بالسلطة
حتى تزايد الاستياء من
وحشية الشرطة والفساد وعدم المساواة
الاقتصادية في 25 يناير 2011 عندما
استخدمت مجموعة من النشطاء الشباب
نظمت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي انتفاضة
فاجأت النظام بعد
18 يومًا  تصاعدت الاحتجاجات في جميع أنحاء البلاد
للمطالبة باستقالته ،
وقدرت منظمات حقوقية
مقتل أكثر من 800 متظاهر في
اشتباكات مع الشرطة وأنصار
مبارك ، لكن المد حول
الحركة ضد مبارك فقط نما
رجل عسكري حتى النهاية ،
تعهد مبارك بأنه لن يتنصل من
واجبه.  كرئيس لمصر ، لكن في
11 فبراير ، استقال أخيرًا وخرج
ملايين المصريين إلى
الشوارع في احتفال صاخب بعد عام
ونصف ، أصدرت محكمة في القاهرة حكمًا
بالسجن مدى الحياة على مبارك لدوره
في مقتل المتظاهرين خلال
الانتفاضة بالكاد.  بعد سبعة أشهر ،
نقضت محكمة الاستئناف هذا القرار
وأُطلق سراح مبارك الضعيف بدون
ضجة كبيرة أو معارضة بعد ست سنوات
من الانتفاضة التي أطاحت به
[موسيقى]
أنت